Kelly Edwards, Staff Writer, Author, Producer:And
my daughter calls me and we had this conversation
and I asked her I saidLily, I think I might want
to give this a shotand she said,oh wow, okay.
Film Courage: Kelly, if you were given a
choice between working as an executive for
$100,000 a year or working as a screenwriter
for $25,000 a year, which would you choose?
Kelly:First of all executives make a lot
more than $100,000 a year. I actually had to
make that decision at the top of 2020 when I was
offered a promotion at HBO and I was going to make
a $100,000 more than I made currently and I turned
it down because also they made me an offer to
take a first look writing deal and I jumped at it
and it was probably half of what I was making. So
I’ve actually had this question in real time,
in real life and there’s nothing like it. I
think if I went back and had to do it all
over again I would make the same choice.
There’s just nothing like waking up every day
in pure joy and knowing that the first thing
that I get to do is crack open my computer and
the last thing I’m doing all day is still being
wired into that computer, just downloading
everything that’s in my head. There’s just
getting paid to write there’s just no question.
Film Courage: Do you think you would have
really taken that? I know you had some jobs
out of college where you were an administrative
assistant or helping agents things like that,
but the lure of six figures or more, do you think
it takes time to realize what is important?
Kelly:Let me see if I understand your
question, if you’re saying did it take me
30 years to know that I wanted to be a writer?
I don’t think I was consciously aware in all
of that time that I was an executive that I was
planning on making a transition. I think I had
started out as a writer's assistant when I was you
know just coming out of college it was one of my I
think it was my third job that I'd ever had in the
entertainment business and I knew that I wanted
to do that I wanted to be a part of the creative
process and I tried casting and I knew that that
wasn't really it even though I loved the process
I love the people I was working with and I think
I was looking for my place and I it felt right
because I'd always been writing I'd been writing
you know since I was a kid you know creating
short plays and short stories and you know doing
all those things actually creating a magazine so
for my family so I knew that I wanted to somehow
channel all that into writing but when I was
coming out of college the world was very different
than it is now there just weren't a lot of places
for an African-American young woman who wanted to
write in in the ecosystem and when I looked around
I didn't see a lot of people who looked like me
either in either in executive ranks or as a as
a writer on staff of a show so I felt as though
there were not a whole lot of doors that were open
for me there were not a lot of places that I could
go so I think if if the world had been different
if I had come out now as a writer if I was doing
that you know when I was 20 something years old
and doing it now boy sky's the limit but at the
time I made the best choice that I could with the
information that I could and with the knowledge
that I needed to make a living and that there were
not going to be a lot of opportunities for me so
so I do feel as though going into as an executive
route was the perfect place for me because I could
still work with the creative I could still be a
part of that writing process only from the hey
let me help you you know let's talk about your
project let's figure out where you want to go
and how to get there and and the packaging part
that you do as you're in a network executive or
as a feature executive so I do feel as
though it really satisfied a lot of those
cravings of working with material
and I think I was really good at it
and I got a chance to see the industry from a very
very different perspective than a lot of writers
do so I saw the in inner workings and realized oh
there are so many different decisions that get in
you know that are part of the of the creative
process that are on the business side
that you don't see as a writer you only know
the work that you've put out but you don't
know all the other things that make into the
decision-making process of why this thing moves
forward versus something else that doesn't move
forward and then once it does move forward well
what else do you have to do in order to support
that piece of material you know from the marketing
and and advertising and all of the other aspects
of it so I think I got a really great insider view
into the business on both the feature side and
the tv side that I probably wouldn't have had so
I kind of feel like I got baked in a different way
I was always writing though and I think that that
that that need for me to express myself on the
page was always there so I don't think you have to
go through 30 years of you know how I did it that
was just a kind of a a weird way to you know for
me to do it but I know that there are there's
also a very long legacy of of executives who
turned writers I don't know that they talk about
it but but it's not like I blazed a whole new path
and I do feel like you know I sort of
got to the right place at the right time
okay so maybe not the 30-year journey maybe
if you were to give advice to someone on
a paycheck versus feeling creatively fulfilled
well I think that's always the balance isn't it
you know I was actually just talking to a group
of people recently about that you know art versus
commerce and how much you know can you survive on
while you were fulfilling your dream and how and
what does success look like to you so you know
there might be writers who are are completely
content having you know doing plays in in
regional theater you know and that's a success as
a writer so I think whatever you feel as though
your calling is in this it doesn't have to be that
you're winning an Oscar doesn't have to be that
you're making a marvel feature you know you can
write and be satisfied by that writing and create
in so many different ways and yeah the money
thing is is it's hard it's harder when you get
older it's certainly harder if I did this when
I was 24 years old and right out of college and
my I think my rent at the time this was back at
80 something my rent at the time was 450 a month
that was it that's all I had to make to cover that
nut now it's like I got a mortgage I've got three
kids there was college education you know there's
a lot more that you know there's there's car
insurance there's homeowners and shares there's
so many things that just become so much more
oppressive and you have to make different choices
based on what's coming in and what's not coming in
I have the luxury now of having an expertise
in something that people want that thing can
support me as I also pursue this writing so if
it's not if it's a lean month you know i'll have
something to fall back on that's the benefit
you know and I think also my age you know at
at my age now there be there's a as I don't know
if it's it's like a feeling of being settled
and knowing that you have worth and you have
value that I don't think I had when I was in
my 20s in my 20s I thought oh it's going to
be my last job ever it was always the thing
oh my god they're never going to hire me I'm
never going to work again you don't have that
when you're in your 50s because you know you've
got something that you're bringing to the table
what about peer pressure family pressure to make
money or maybe it's not even spoken it's just oh
hey it's a family get together and so and so they
just now their partner at a new firm and what are
you up to you know that kind of thing where you
know you feel like you have to explain yourself
I think I have the benefit of coming from a family
that's incredibly supportive and my mother who
is my biggest cheerleader and and every single
morning you know calls me up and says you know
calls me her precious child and just thinks that
I'm a genius so I think that that's that helps
and when I made this decision to to jump off the
edge of the cliff I happen I know exactly when it
was I could probably even pinpoint the day and the
moment because it was very very important to me
I happened to be at Sundance I was in the episodic
lab this is 2019. It was in October it was
the day before we were going to finish the program
and and it probably was a Saturday actually if I'm
really being specific and I was in line to get
my to get dinner it was a buffet line and my
daughter calls me and we had this conversation
and I asked her I said I said Lily I think I
might want to give this a shot and she said
oh wow okay she said if not now mom when
and for me I was like I birthed the
right child because I said look it
we might actually end up having to have
you know make some choices financially
because look I was coming off of a really nice
svp job at a major studio you know network and
and she just said hey we'll be okay we'll figure
it out and at this point I think my my kids were
I think I was probably I don't know I'm trying to
think if I just graduated from my MFA program or I
think I had just graduated from my MFA program
and they my kids were still in school so they
were still you know it was their last year of
college and I think her last year of maybe of
her graduate school and and again I feel like
there was just this understanding that we could
all figure it out together and that it wasn't that
important that the trappings of life the cars the
house the whatever the vacations that we would
go on were just not that important compared to
mom finding herself and I just couldn't have asked
for a better support system so I do feel as though
when you're when you're somebody who doesn't have
that when you have to really struggle and you
have to do that for yourself you do need to find
people who are going to acknowledge your dream
and support your dream and to encourage your
dream because I think that a lot of writers
I think that's probably the biggest thing
that's the that's one of the biggest hurdles
I think imposter syndrome and the the fact that
no one's in your corner saying hey keep going
that's what makes us give up right
that's what makes us feel like
you know maybe we're you know charging
in the wrong direction or we're
we're not on the right path because there are
all these pressures they're all these people who
who you know until you until you've made
something until you've until you've gotten that
acknowledgement you don't know if you're doing the
right thing you just don't know and I've I think
I've seen a lot of interviews with a lot of people
who have made it and they still don't know they
still worry they still don't know if what they
have created is anything that's worthy of being
seen or shown or read so I do feel as though
there's a there's you got to close that gap
someplace and luckily I had I had a whole team of
people who were willing to help me close that gap
does Lily want to be a writer creative you know
I keep asking Lily if she would if she would do
it she's a beautiful writer she had to write
she she went to college and got a a degree
in American studies and film and the the pieces
that she wrote were just wonderful it drives her
bananas she doesn't love the process but I think
that's also maybe a factor of age as well because
at that age for me writing was a chore and and I
did not enjoy it now I enjoy it now I enjoy the
cracking it open trying to figure out the pieces
of the puzzle that make it work so it might be
that she will get there eventually which which she
is amazing at and by the way she's my assistant
now and I’d be lost without her but what she's
amazing at is finding material so she will because
she's an avid reader and I'm I believe her she
and her sister Sarah last year read between 35
and 38 books just and that's just them that's they
just turn and consume material and she found me a
project that ended up getting an offer from a
studio so she's really good and I really trust
her instincts so I would love it if she would
right I'm not sure that she will but I'm also
seeing if she I would push her to if she wanted to
be a development executive she'd be great at it.